guys I'm telling you this is it this is
this is I've tried everything okay this
is my shining moment as a father for you
I've tried wrapping up a pancake like a
burrito with syrup on it but that gets
way too messy I've tried taking a bite
of a pancake then just pouring syrup
into my mouth to get that right ratio
that has not worked
what I have found works the best is you
cut the center out of the pancake right
you remove the center then you pour
syrup into the center so that's gonna
soak up that syrup right in the middle
and that's going to be the best part of
the pancake plus what you've done
without even knowing it is you've saved
the middle of the pancake that's the
greatest bite add pancake history Dad
don't you have to go to a show
figure out the tip who's gonna do it I
got it I got it because I know for every
ten dollars you leave a two dollar bill
so this is thirty dollars so that's
three two dollar bills that's six money
that's perfect man that's actually a
great way to think about it way to go
yeah don't forget your passport
all right we gotta move let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Chad Daniels
hi everyone
all right
hello hi
I'm glad you're here
this is uh this is gonna be okay
I want you to know that I know that I
don't look like you thought I would
take it in
I realize that my kids remind me that
I've gotten older every day comma every
day
I dropped my son off one time and he
goes God you've aged like a president
and then my daughter goes I was thinking
guacamole
so you know they're pretty cool right
yeah great
I grew a beard that can make a guy look
older but I grew a beer for two reasons
number one beards are like sweatpants
for your face
doesn't matter how chubby you're getting
when you're wearing one
man I grew a beard for a whole year and
then shaved it to the skin what an
[ __ ] who does that
I mean just in one thing I looked in the
mirror and I was like no no no no no no
no no it was crazy
what was I doing
just sat in my bathroom all night going
trying to push hair out of my face
but that's just how you hurt your back
the other reason I I grew a beard is
because my 18 year old son challenged me
to a beard growing contest and uh he
lost because he is 18.
you ever seen an 18 year old's beard oh
my God they're so gross
it's like a daddy long leg he's just
crawling out feet first
like a whisker up here and a whisker
over here I have a grandmother that
could beat this kid in a beard growing
contest
using only moles
I think my son challenged me to a beer
growing contest because pubic hair grew
in on other parts of his body
and that grew in full
does that is how Pubic Hair Works
nobody has patchy pubes
let me rephrase that I don't think
anybody has patchy feet
some of you shut down on that one you're
like hey buddy right here
what are you doing out of the house
stay home and fix your dick mange or
whatever it's it's probably not called
that but that's what I'm gonna call it
I have never seen pubic hair on my son's
body but I have for sure seen it shaved
off of his body onto my toilet seat
you know where my toilet seat is that's
in my bathroom that's an easy one
everyone should have got that
do you know where my bathroom is that is
in my bedroom
so that means he
walked through my bedroom and he's not
allowed in there
because clothes go missing and pillows
get moved and I don't trust that
a crooked pillow is a mystery I don't
want to solve
so that goes in the garbage immediately
I just picture him straddling my toilet
and I know I know he straddled it
because there are only pubes on the back
half of the toilet seat
if you have a better Theory I'll listen
but there isn't one that's the only way
because I know he wasn't using painters
tape and [ __ ] to like Straighten It Out
Hold on it's not even yet let me get a
laser level I got it
just over my toilet
he's making a pair of Ugg boots
walking out of my bathroom like [ __ ] it
my dad will clean it up
and I don't try
whatever kids say when you're not around
now the main problem I have with these
pubes on the toilet
is that during this story my kids live
with me Sunday to Wednesday they live
with their mother Wednesday to Sunday
and yeah he shaved his pubes Wednesday
before he went to school
that means he was not going to be home
for four days
so I called the cell phone when he was
at school to leave a message but he
answered because he's not a good student
and I said hey man found some pubes
and he said where
which leads me to believe
I have not found all the pukes
what do you mean where why are there
options to this conversation
am I going to happen upon more pubes
later this afternoon
boy I sure hope not because I taught him
how to prank and I know he's real good
at it
I haven't checked but I bet you there
are pubes in my sleeping bag right now
that's a hard ass burn
nobody naps when they're camping the
first time you get in that bag the food
is in the tree and the fire is out and
you're like oh I can't wait to get some
oh those are pubes
you got me
so I said hey man why'd you shave the
pubes at my house and he goes because
mom's not there to yell at me
and I said that is the dumbest answer
I've ever heard
so get back here after school and clean
these up and he said I'm sorry father
but according to the custody agreement I
am at mothers now
and I know that was meant to make me mad
but it didn't
I was thrilled to use two three syllable
words in one sentence
because I have watched him walk into a
wall during the daytime
natural sunlight guiding his way and
just still funk
so I waited till Sunday and he came to
my house and said hey man come give me a
hug and he came to give me a hug like
this and when he did I spun him around
and I put him in a Full Nelson and I
walked him up the stairs and I walked
him into my bathroom and I bent him over
the toilet like I was rubbing a dog's
nose in its own [ __ ]
[Applause]
because the pubes were still there
they're not mine I'm not cleaning those
off
I walked downstairs in my own home for
four straight days to use the bathroom
because I am committed to parenting
all right
so
so I haven't bent over the toilet and he
starts making the weirdest noise he
started going
like that
and I panicked a little bit because when
he was two he had asthma when he was
seven it went away because of a
nebulizer and I thought oh my god did I
give my kid back asthma
but I didn't
turns out he was just blowing pube dust
to create a clean breathing area
once I figured that out I could not stop
laughing
because I had come to the realization my
son is pubic hair waterboarding himself
and that hits the spot
I was laughing so hard my grip loosened
he finally Wiggles around and he goes
why are you doing this to me
because your mom's not here to yell at
me anymore either
thank you
I used to have a story
about uh when my son turned 18 I was
gonna punch him in the face
[Applause]
he's 18 now
on his birthday I got up
I got up early I set my alarm
and it went downstairs and I made myself
a good breakfast
and then I heard him getting up
and I go here we go
it's game time
my heart started racing my hands got
sweaty mom's spaghetti
[Applause]
so dumb
oh God
I sort of give myself a pep talk I was
like you can punch him he's 18. you can
do this because you did not spank him
and these are all the spankings
that he should have coming to him
and then I heard him coming down the
stairs so I started walking towards the
bottom of the staircase and then he
turned the corner and I just saw a
little boy walking towards me and I was
like you can't punch this little boy but
here's what you can do you can put a
hockey helmet on him and hockey gloves
and then you can put those on as well
and we can go in the backyard and we can
lock her box
so that's what we did
and I kept hitting him in the shoulder
and he goes it doesn't even hurt what
are you doing
and I was like all right just wait
and in the third round he could not lift
his hands up to protect his face
that's old man knowledge
president Style
after we Locker boxed I went inside and
I checked my social media and there were
over a thousand messages asking if I had
punched my son in the face
happy birthday
that's the kind of world we live in I
guess
so I replied to all these messages I
said uh no I I couldn't punch him in the
face I didn't think it'd be fair to him
so instead we went in the backyard and
we Locker boxed and then I put my phone
away
and then 24 hours later I checked and I
had a message from a man in Little Rock
Arkansas and he had replied back to me
with a picture of Urban Dictionary's
definition of locker box
and I would like to tell you
that it is not what I thought
Urban Dictionary's definition of locker
box is when you're having sex with
someone you also shove your nuts into
them
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean where do you even start
God
do people do that and if so how how do
you do that
the only thing I know about that sexual
position is you probably need the lights
on
that does not seem like a feel-around
job to finish it
so anyways I sent over 1 000 people
a message from my home computer
that said now man I didn't punch him in
the face
you know because that wouldn't be fair
instead
I brought him in the backyard
[Applause]
I put my balls up there
thank you
for like a week I was nervous that the
green light on my computer was going to
come on on the camera and it would just
be the feds like what else is going on
over there creep all right
my son no longer lives with me
not because of locker boxing or whatever
but
he uh he went to one semester of college
and didn't like it and I get that I
didn't like college either so that's
that's fair for me but he also didn't
want to get a job and that's where I
drew the line because I just I just
can't
so I let him go through the holidays we
did all that stuff hung out a lot and
then January 1st I said you owe me 400
rent
and then
um if you don't have a job by February
1st I'm going to kick you out
if you do have a job by February 1st I'm
going to give you 200 of that 400 back
and we're going to call that a happy
father rebate
and then if you have a job the first of
every month you're going to pay me 200
rent for the rest of time until I kick
you out permanently and he goes 200
what about 150 and I buy my own milk
who in the [ __ ] drinks fifty dollars
worth of milk in a year are you having
bone problems what's going on
that's probably why I can't find a job
he's a horrible negotiator
we'll give you 17 an hour what about 16
and I'll drive myself here
[Applause]
well you would be expected 14.
okay we're no longer hiring
the first month my son left my electric
bill went down eighty dollars
that's a lot
want to know why because his hobby is
leaving my lights on
it's like a passion project for him
he wears a Fitbit around his wrists and
I bet you he gets 10 000 steps a day
just turning my goddamn lights on
all around the house
that's a lot of green all right
I know all my lights are on at all times
because I live in a place where a lot of
people like to hunt but my friends will
get up early at four in the morning and
they'll drive out to hunt and they'll go
by my house and then they'll call me and
say hey are you home I go no why because
all your lights are wrong
well which ones yeah all of them
porch to garage buddy ports took her out
thank you
and you want to know why they're on
because my son's scared when he's there
by himself
that's the only logical reason
he's tough I mean he like wanted to live
there right he didn't live with he
doesn't live with me full time at that
point you know because he loves me more
than his mom no because he wanted the
freedom when I was on the road working
I'm tough I'm gonna live with my dad's
house
when he's gone it's going to be my house
because I'm tough
until the wind blows a tree and the
branch scratches the house
just the steps
operation sunshine
still running into walls
I also have a 14 year old daughter and I
gave her a chore list with three words
on it and she goes where's your chore
list
you ever had a kid say something to you
that then they're serious but then you
almost ruin it because you laugh
that's what I was like oh girl what
and I just go what did you say and she
goes where's your truck she slowed it
down like I didn't like I actually
didn't hear her you know
so I said you know everything that
happens in this house to make this home
operate subtract the three things I
asked you to do and that is my chore
list
remember when you woke up in a bed warm
and not hungry [ __ ] check check
I did that [ __ ]
so my chore list also has three words on
it and it says keep her alive
and it expires in four years so Focus
she's 14 now she was 12. I started
listening to podcasts about periods
and I know that seems creepy
I'm positive I'm on a list somewhere
but I never wanted to be the dad that
had to send her to her mom to ask her
all those questions I don't want you
know like that's a question for your mom
you know where to find me if you want to
play catch I mean it's like ridiculous
right
so
I uh I was listening to these podcasts
but I had to stop because one of them
kind of creeped me out
it said if you're going to show your
daughter how to use a tampon you push it
into your hand and then so I was like
well yeah my hand's been a vagina okay
that makes sense
sure
if you're looking for a number you're
not going to get it
just know that it has been
but then I pictured myself pushing a
tampon into my hand and oh my God it
just looks like a magic trick
just like hey
[Music]
[Applause]
where's the tampon
you better find it because toxic shock
is real
[Applause]
my daughter got her period at my house
for the first time
and she came downstairs and she goes uh
dad two things number one got my period
number two don't want to talk about it
I was like number one great number two
greater
and she said I have to go to Mom's house
because she bought me some stuff and I
said I don't know if you've heard about
the new legislation that was just passed
but dads are now allowed to buy things
they're letting us out of the house
so I said come upstairs and we went
upstairs and I opened the closet next to
the laundry room and in there was one
box of all of the each
I had all the kinds all every box that
they make
or at least they were at the store
because I got there and I was like oh
that's different all right oh that's
different too and I got all of them
and that costs 217 dollars where I live
[Applause]
[Music]
and I said whatever you need for this is
going to be in here
because that is every kind they don't
make any more than that
if you need something that isn't in
there
sorry about your Square vagina
[Applause]
foreign
and in that case we are going to have to
call your mom
because she's way better at making
appointments
and then she just goes God you're so
dumb and she grabbed it box she goes
it's right here I know what I need and
then she left
I don't have anything to do so I brought
back 211 dollars worth of tampon
that is an interesting Exchange
there were so many boxes left and you
can't carry them in because they're all
individual boxes so I had to walk into
Target get an empty cart and just walk
out with an empty cart and people were
like is this [ __ ] stealing a car what
is going on
so then I loaded it up with all the
tampons and I brought it back in and I
brought it to The Exchange counter and
the guy goes uh you checking out and I
go hmm checking in
foreign
[Music]
I mean what happened
that is a reasonable question
but I didn't know I was going to get
asked so I panicked and I just went uh
she said pancake mix
[Applause]
foreign
if we could get this done everybody's
real hungry at the house
in my opinion
it is harder raising a 14 year old
daughter and an 18 year old son than
when they were little because when they
were little I could give them all the
same rules I could sit them down on the
couch and both of them I could say hey
don't break anything don't drink my
chocolate milk and go outside till it's
dark
right and they'd go all right Dad and
that was it
but now I can't do that I have to give
them individual rules and that takes
longer and I don't like it I don't think
well I also don't think it's fair right
I have to tell my daughter oh you're
going to a party okay well keep your
water bottle close to you and keep the
cap on and uh you know don't if you're
gonna play hide and seek please don't
run into the woods with four boys even
if they're your friends because people
could start talking and then that's not
gonna be great
I don't have to tell that to my son hey
if you're going to a party please don't
run into the woods with four girls
because people could start talking and
then they're gonna think you're awesome
that's a really weird double standard
that I don't like
I tell my daughter a ton of stuff when
she leaves the house you know what I
tell my son drive safe don't rape that's
it
that is it
that is every single thing I want him to
know
and some you might be like you can't say
rape Chad well you sure can if you say
don't in front of it
yeah that's like the number one time
they want you saying it I'm pretty sure
[Applause]
one time I got after a show honestly
asked me he goes why would you tell your
son drive safe don't rape and I just was
like I really did think that was
self-explanatory
but if you're looking for an answer here
it is I want him to arrive safely
and then when he does to not rape anyone
I don't think he's going to but it
doesn't hurt to remind people
of big things
drive safe
don't rape that's four words they're all
one syllable
sounds like a caveman
[Music]
and that works well for 18 year old boys
because they are cavemen
me
yeah you buddy
you for sure but everybody everybody
hit you and me just sector right
there you go
good
[Applause]
okay Dad
me got it
fire good
yeah fire is good
right band
Isaac smart
Isaac smart
I'm gonna start saying that Everywhere I
Go
I mean not like a caveman because that
would creep people out of course
can't walk down the street
yeah we're gonna be like oh he lost his
chaperone
I think it's a good message
I think guys should say it to guys all
the time
I don't think there's any harm in it
plus they're going to learn a lot about
someone that you say it to
right and here's a change have a great
day thank you so much don't rape
why would you say don't rape to me
if that ever happens to you you are face
to face with a rapist
because why else would you freak out
that much
I thought about it if I was walking down
the street and somebody goes hey man
don't rape but be like oh my God I was
just thinking that thank you
you too
I've also told my son that if he's on a
date and it's not going well that he
doesn't want a second date but the girl
wants to kiss him at the end of that
date well just don't
because that's going to be a real
awkward situation later on it's going to
be awkward for sure in those five
minutes
but that's okay that's five minutes
you don't want to have that [ __ ] go on
forever and if you don't believe me why
don't you call Aziz see what he thinks
about it
that come out of the mic wrong what
happened
how's he's got in trouble
for having a bad day
he's a famous comedian for those either
don't know and uh there was a girl that
he went on a date with and he wanted to
have sex with that girl and she wanted a
famous boyfriend and neither of that
worked
there is so much dumb on both sides of
this story it is mind-blowing to me
for those of you that never read the
article here's what happened
they got home from dinner she sat on his
kitchen counter and then they both
agreed that he was going to put his this
part
on her this part
immediately when they got home
it's like a kid hitting a ball at little
league and running right to Third
[Applause]
I mean yeah it's adorable but there are
rules here
then they both agreed that she was going
to put her this far on his this part two
times
gentlemen I think we can all agree that
no means no every single time but what
about uh-huh even then for sure
[Applause]
but then ladies you also have to agree
that no one can hear you saying no when
you voluntarily put their dick in your
mouth two times
[Applause]
in the article she was quoted as saying
he wasn't getting my non-verbal cues
well where I'm from sucking a dick is
not a good one
[Applause]
I'm not having any fun
I mean that is not how you call Uber
everybody knows that
it's an app
[Music]
the reason I bring this up is because I
think sometimes we shift the spotlight
from where it needs to be right my
daughter's 14. I'd like to have this
[ __ ] figured out in four years
we do we shifted the metoo movement is
super serious have you read some of the
stories they're gut-wrenching and
heartbreaking and then there are some
where it's just like all right there's a
lady from Michigan who got her ass
grabbed by President Bush senior 27
years ago and that was her metoo story
and like you read the other ones and
you're like how are you limping in with
this [ __ ]
he didn't finger your [ __ ]
I want to be very very
about something in no
feel like all of us learn at a very
young age to not stand in front of an
old man for any reason at all
they are the grossest
things not people things on the whole
planet
it goes old men monkeys seaweed
those are the top three grossest things
on the whole planet Earth monkeys throw
[ __ ] at you
yeah that's an easy number two I get it
seaweed messes with you when you're
swimming you don't know what it is you
can't see underwater
[Applause]
old men do both of those things
[Applause]
[Music]
an old man will throw [ __ ] up into the
air so you look at it just so he can
give you a wet willy there are the
creepiest
things ever
have you ever swam with an old man it's
always just like
bad bad like their tits floating on top
of the water
like an oil spill like when you make a
pancake you know what I'm talking how it
spreads out just I'd rather get eaten by
a shark at that point that's real
now some people may think Chad you just
think this way because you're a man well
that has to be part of it my brain has
been connected to a dick for quite a
while
but I would believe that all of our
lenses are tinted from several different
things I was also raised by a very
strong single mother and so I watched
her operate in different situations and
that's what I learned if my mom would
have got her ass grabbed by anyone
doesn't matter if it's a president she
wouldn't have went away for 27 years she
would have done one of two things
immediately she would have turned around
and said do it again and I'm gonna break
your hand
or she would have just yelled this piece
of [ __ ] just grabbed my ass
and
yeah
I don't know if you know this but that's
how you end the picnic
and my sister and I would have been just
cowering in the car like oh man we
should clean the house when we get home
uh you know because she's pretty mad did
you see what happened I didn't even see
it but there was an old guy surprised
him
I live in the same small town where I
grew up and nobody likes me from a long
time ago
I don't know
[Applause]
and I know that sounds sad but it's
pretty freeing
but I can say whatever I want I'm not
going to lose friends
I'm there
I was at a small Cafe and a woman was
reading the article about the lady for
Michigan and she said can you believe
this and I said uh that they would waste
that much ink on that no I can't and
then everyone turn their chair to look
at both of us like we were going to
Locker box or something
all right
and she said I will have you know a
female American president would never
grab an ass and I said well neither
would a unicorn because neither of them
exist
[Applause]
you can get as mad as you want
can't do an experiment with a group that
doesn't have any [ __ ] people in it
[Applause]
I thought she had it locked she wears
pantsuits on purpose
what a great presidential candidate
but 45 of people that looked just like
her said maybe next time
you want to know why
because women don't get along
and I know there's this movement yes we
do but you don't
you're at the movement with a picket
sign and you have the same one you're
like oh [ __ ] this I mean it's
and that's sad to me because you're
easily the better of the two Sexes you
should own everything but you're busy
bickering your way to second place it's
crazy to me
a man could punch a man in the face and
have a beer with that saved man five
minutes later a lady could hear some
[ __ ] she maybe thought was about her and
hate that [ __ ] till she dies
it's crazy you guys
why are you doing that
here's my theory I feel like you don't
get along because you've been pit
against one another since you were
little kids right you're going to school
oh you better get all cute and get
pigtails so you can find a boy you don't
want to be an old maid right that's
crazy that you had to listen to that
[ __ ]
how is the human species the only
species where women have to look nice
have you seen nature
yeah
have you seen a beautiful peacock that's
a dude
that's a dude peacock just
ever seen a female peacock [ __ ] gross
they're like they're Gray
they're gray and just sloppy
but they have a vagina
so they win the whole thing
women you should not ever have to put on
makeup you should be able to walk into a
bar and just go I'll be in the car
foreign
[Applause]
I also think it would be nice if we
could all have the same rules let's make
a big rule book that everybody agrees on
I think being an individual is amazing
and what makes the planet great however
everyone has their own rules and you
can't get to know someone in a day for
all their rules right so there I have a
friend on Facebook and she posted am I
ever going to be able to go to a bar by
myself and not have a man ask if I'm
okay
and no is the answer
and that sucks but it worked once I
don't know when let's say the 40s
there was a lady drinking a drink all by
herself in the bar
and a man walked in and he goes are you
okay
and then they had sex and he told
everyone he'd ever met
that story's been passed down from
generation to generation little boys are
walking home from their grandfather's
homes like ask if she's okay ask if
she's okay ask if she's okay
because we're simple creatures we go
with what works
in seventh grade a teacher told me I
look nice in sweaters well here we are
[Applause]
[Music]
now some of you like me again that's
good welcome back
welcome back
I try to stay out of uh the rest of the
politics because it's it's too demanding
right and I like to sleep so
hey Chad did you hear about no I didn't
good night
like my new move
I do think politics divides us and makes
us softer because I mean people are so
fake taken aback when it comes to every
opinion they're like I don't want my
friend to think that I think this and
they don't think that and everybody oh
my God I'm surprised we haven't changed
our national anthem to
foreign
I know we're getting soft as a country
because one time I heard a guy go if I
could just be half the man my father was
well you are that's how genetics works
you're also half the woman your mom was
and you're acting like her right now so
get your [ __ ] together
and I'll tell you this I don't even like
that joke I just like to watch some of
the women laugh and some of the women
not laugh because it proves you don't
get along it's it's crazy
it's probably just said it and you're
back on track already
all right
I think we're getting softer as a
country people say sorry all the time
when they don't need to
right never been bumped into and
somebody goes oh sorry yeah for what you
just barely bumped into me
have you been planning this for two
weeks
because then an apology is necessary but
this seems like an excuse me moment
right like what are you gonna say when
someone important to me dies
like oh I'm so sorry same way like when
you bumped into me
I went to Starbucks once I go hey man
are you in line the guy goes yeah I am
sorry yeah for what getting here faster
so I stood right in front of him
and he goes hey man I am in line I go
yeah but you're sorry so
just trying to help with the guilt
my daughter says sorry non-stop my
daughter will say sorry three times for
the same thing
and now you're just being an [ __ ]
sorry once you can't keep doing it and
think sorry is going to get you off the
hook so I have a swear jar in my house
that costs you a quarter I have a sorry
jar that will cost you a dollar
what's the lesson there call your dad a
piece of [ __ ] just don't apologize for
it
because that is a 400 markup
my home is also filled with hyperbole
because of my daughter everything is the
best or the worst or the funniest
and can I tell you something it never is
you know something's going to be really
funny when someone laughs all the way
through it right Dad you're not gonna
believe that's the funniest thing ever
happened to me oh my God oh my God
okay let's hear it there's a girl
running through the hall and her shoe
fell off and here's the funniest thing
you've ever seen him oh Dad please
when either one of my kids tells me
stories my face must just glaze over
it's all I am thinking is how in the
world do some people have sex with their
own children does that make sense to
anyone else in this room how does a
human brain allow that kind of [ __ ] to
take place I am so utterly turned off by
both of my kids in every single way
and by the way if you're not laughing
right now you're the creepiest person in
this world
because that as easily as anti-kid
touching As It Gets
I said how in the world you know Earth
the world the whole one
do some people have sex with their own
children and some of you in uh
I'm protected Second Amendment
[Applause]
everybody knows you can't change an
amendment Chad because amend means all
right hold on
[Applause]
that's how I'm gonna start choosing
hotels when I'm on the road I'm going to
walk into a Lobby and be like how in the
world do some people have sex with their
own children and if no one even looks up
I'll be like okay cool next hotel
sometimes when I tell that story someone
will laugh so hard their shoulders will
shake
and other times someone won't even smile
but on a magical night those two people
are sitting right next to each other
and I get so excited about the idea of
that uncomfortable ride home
Erica do you care if we stop by the gas
station and get some Skittles I don't
know Patrick why don't you go [ __ ] a kid
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign
you heard me say Skittles right
[Applause]
I know we're getting soft as a nation
because I travel all around it and I
hear soft noises in comedy clubs one
time I heard a grown man go mole
crazy
that is the noise your body chooses to
make stay home always and forever
because no one likes you for sure
but the worst noise I've ever heard in a
comedy show is this one I don't
man or woman that is the twatiest noise
that can come out of the human body
you should be able to karate chop that
out of somebody's throat
hey man how was your day I don't flap
I would rather hear choking than hear
that noise
because you know who makes that noise
people that wake up every morning and
think how could I be a victim today
and you know who I'm talking about
people that don't get enough attention
at work they don't get enough attention
at home
so they're on social media posting all
these vague ass statuses
sure could use some prayers today
post
it's like you can almost hear them
typing it I don't I don't I don't I
don't I don't I don't have to be kidding
me knock it off what do you need prayers
for be specific
everybody's worried sick about you
there's 150 comments and they're all
some version of Mary sending good vibes
your way
raising the roof with prayer emoji
and four days later Mary comes back
Tomatoes weren't as red as I'd hoped
well [ __ ] you Mary
I hope you get lupus and everybody's all
prayed out
foreign
[Applause]
right they'll have antioxidants won't
they mayor
best of luck to you little girl that
cried prayer
how can we not test for the noise I
don't
we can test for almost anything in utero
right let's get one of those fancy
ultrasound machines and figure it out
that's your baby's heartbeat
hmm I don't um we should get that out of
you immediately
nobody wants another one of those
walking around
and you do not want to live with a third
grader that doesn't want Oreos because
they're made with hydrogenated oil I
don't [ __ ] die
just
die die
when I hear the noise I don't um
I get Isis
I got it
I understand starting a group to hurt
other people
sense to me
does that mean I'm a joint Isis of
course not would I Scout for them I
don't know probably
[Applause]
hey man how was your salad I don't
I found one
you don't want to mess with Isis man
they're a crabby Groove
and we should have seen that coming
because they are all caps
and you guys that's yelling how did we
not know
I bet if you asked everybody in Isis why
they joined over 40 would say traffic
traffic can turn a reasonable rational
human being a murderous monster
you ever been at a four-way stop and
it's not your turn to go but it's a
person in front of you it's their turn
to go but they're not going they're
doing this go go go go go go go go go go
no you oh good good good good good go
and you're behind him like [ __ ] [ __ ]
go
you have to go or nobody's ever gonna go
there are rules in place for this
situation
not going to get into heaven for letting
somebody go first in a four-way stop
because I'm gonna stab someone and that
shit's going on your task because go go
go go go go it's going to lead to Gaga
[Applause]
listen you guys you cannot be nice with
someone else's time that is not how
kindness works if you want to be nice
join the big brother or the big sister
program and bring a kid to the movie but
on your way to the theater [ __ ] go
you have to go
[Applause]
now I want you to know traffic is the
only time I get real upset
that's true I'm a pretty laid-back guy I
love walking around and seeing other
people get mad I think that's fun
because I am a hypocrite and I like to
judge others
and that makes me feel good
if I see a man yelling at his kids I'm
like oh I'm so much better than him
and that gets me through my day even
though it's not true
my favorite kind of anger is
self-produced anger we've all seen that
guy at the grocery store is holding the
door somebody walks in doesn't say thank
you and the guy holding the door is like
welcome
my God has anyone ever needed to hear
drive safe don't rate more than him
like ever
what does he think
getting in shape sure hope somebody
holds the door at the store today cannot
wait to say thank you
crazy people have other things going on
in their lives right even if it's
something as small as remembering your
list when you're walking through the
parking lot just milk eggs flour welcome
okay all right
yeah that was most likely for me
were you holding the door you were right
yeah I was just trying to remember my
list yeah well you're welcome
nobody likes getting yelled at
especially in public nothing good has
ever happened from that a guy is never
like oh I should take that guy fishing
right it's always something like I'd
kill him for sure
that's why I admire Psychopaths a little
bit
I think Psychopaths have figured some
things out I do
a psychopath thinks I'm gonna kill that
guy and then they just kill him
and the rest of the day they're like
they're just so happy that their to-do
list is done
but a man that fears society's rules you
can't go killing people all willy-nilly
Ryan she's like oh I'm gonna kill that
guy but uh I'm already at the store I
should probably just get my stuff
yeah I'll do that and then he goes in
the store but he hasn't forgotten that
he's been yelled out right so 10 minutes
later he's walking around the frozen
food section just like okay hold on what
do you mean I'm welcome
why am I welcome you're welcome how
about that you ever thought about that
how about you be welcome
I'll just open this freezer door didn't
need your help there did I no man I got
doors all day [ __ ] welcome and he
Strokes out in the frozen food section
and he forgets his list and he goes home
without milk eggs or flour and his only
job all week was to make his little
daughter a birthday cake
[Applause]
you [ __ ]
I mean seriously
let's review all the things we've talked
about tonight
and Cake just shot you down huh
we've talked about so many topics you're
like not the cake don't you dare
my God you're so nice
the Lord is alive in Denver
weirdos
just as a reminder a man had just
stroked out in a grocery store and
nobody had any problem with that at all
and then I mentioned a girl not getting
cake and you're like oh God is there a
bakery he could stop at
stop it of B3 and get some okay it's her
birthday
I need you to know something when I
wrote this story I never even thought
about that little girl for more than one
second
I just needed something to do with those
ingredients
so I picked cake because I like cake
this little girl is just supposed to go
hey guys and then leave the story that's
it she's like one second in one second
out and you guys are like come here
we'll get you some cake come on come
here right now
[Applause]
this story is about a man on the verge
of a mental breakdown
I just picture this man in his kitchen
stirring an empty bowl with dead eyes
still has his Hospital bracelet on from
the stroke
just mumbling things like hold the door
for me
I do need you to hook those automatic
door you were waving at the camera
okay
his father-in-law walks in the kitchen
how's the cake coming
[Applause]
[ __ ] his mind
[Applause]
[Music]
and a whole bunch of you were like is
there frosting at the house
we get this kid some frosting
which is crazy to me
because the point of this entire story
is this
when a woman is breastfeeding a child
and the child is sick
that illness
is in the child's saliva it enters the
mother's body through the areola it
travels around the mother's body the
mother's body fixes it it puts it back
in the milk sends the Cure out through
the nipple kid feels better
our noses can categorize 50 000 smells
our eyeballs can see 10 million
different colors that is the potential
of the human body
and you can't figure out a four-way stop
I know I have had a lot of problems with
Humanity up here tonight
but I also want you to know I think I
could be friends with almost anybody
I mean the only group of people I can
think of that I wouldn't be friends with
is if we're walking down the street and
we overhear somebody say finger bang and
you don't even giggle thank you
then I don't care to have you a part of
my life as a part of my life
or we're gonna go to your house and
drink gin and do accounting no thank you
if you're an adult and you hear finger
bang and you don't even go okay or like
nothing
that creeps me out
that's why I like talking to really old
people like 95 years or older you can
say whatever you want around them
they're just glad you're talking
you could say finger bang in front of a
95 year old woman and she'd be like I
remember finger banging
it was fingered by Abraham Lincoln's
nephew
also a tall man huge hands
I remember he removed his riding glove
and it was like a fistful of dicks
it was thrilling
President Lincoln once said A House
Divided cannot stand well neither could
I
foreign
[Music]
that's how old man ended up as the
creepiest things on the planet
I can't wait to be that old
I cannot wait until my actions don't
have consequences
I'm not gonna throw [ __ ] at people or be
weird when I'm swimming but I still want
to have fun
when comedy's done I don't have hobbies
so I'm not going to whittle recorders
out of wood and bring them to Middle
Schools
I'm just gonna sit at the bus stop and
then I'm gonna flip guys in the dick
when they walk by
and I know comedy's supposed to be
smarter than that but I don't care
flicking dicks is really funny dude
I'm just gonna sit at the bus stop with
a big coat on but my arms not in the
sleeves
then I'm gonna sneak attack out the
zipper
what are you doing doesn't matter I'm
old
well I'm gonna call the cops go ahead I
need a ride home
they're not going to arrest an old man
for flicking dicks right
it's probably not even in the book
hey uh
we're down at the uh bus stop and we
have a
we have a
there's an old guy down here flicking
dicks and
dude it is outrageous
I don't know he's killing people it's
crazy I don't know if his right shoulder
is made up of only fast twitch muscle
fibers but this guy's unreal he's
beating younger men to their crotches
and my God is it fun to watch and you
know my rule if I laugh at something I
don't make an arrest so
I'm just gonna eat my lunch here and
watch over
because dicks are not protected by the
law
and I'm in no way saying they should be
I'm telling you straight up they're not
you flick a lady in the tit well pack
your [ __ ] because you're going to jail
as it should be
but you could curb stomp
a guy's bare dick
in front of a cop
and the cop would be like it's probably
gonna be a stomach ache catch you guys
later
nobody cares about dicks
that's why sometimes when I hear women
go we want equality I always just want
to whisper yeah but not all of it
you don't want the curb stomping part
just take the good stuff take the M M's
off the trail mix leave the raisins
because if you have equality across the
board and you get the good stuff you're
gonna have to do things you don't want
to do like start calling your shots when
you play pool
foreign
hold on for one second
[Applause]
I saw some women react like I said you
were bad at pool those words never came
out of my mouth I never said women are
bad at pool I said you're cheaters
that's different
it's gonna be no more of this oops I
made it in the wrong pocket but I'm cute
and you want to [ __ ] me so it's still my
turn still my turn still my turn that
goes out the door with equal pay
now you're gonna have to buy your own
drinks and they're 17.50 a piece you
didn't even know that did you yeah back
of the line yoga pants it's a quality
night
if we have true equality between men and
women we're going to be able to fist
fight in the middle of the street
and I can tell you I don't want to live
in a world like that
because I would lose to upwards of 45 of
women
sounds like a high number but let's go
through the groups
white trash ladies uh-huh
and lose to most of them
because they're tricky
they've had to get out of some tight
spots by thinking on their feet
a white trash lady will say something
like look at my tits and when you do
they hit you with something real hard
probably a glass Ash trip
[Applause]
you ever seen a kung fu movie little
Asian girl skipping to school old Asian
guy walks around the corner you're
skipping is stupid and she floats up
into the air and murders him with face
kicks
you're gonna have to factor in all
little Asian girls to that
every single one of them because you
don't know which ones can float
they don't put stickers on them
[Music]
you're going to have to factor in all
black women that start removing their
earrings as they're moving towards you
[Applause]
because I don't care what martial art
you've trained in gentlemen that's going
to be a loss on your record
if you make a black woman so upset with
you for whatever [ __ ] you're doing
and she pulls her earring off and goes
what just go nothing nothing and you run
and you find shelter
and may I suggest a body of water
[Applause]
now
some of you are going to be pretty
surprised by this next part
because a lot of you think I think black
people don't swim and that's the
craziest thing I've ever heard in my
whole life you can't think an entire
group of people doesn't do one thing
that's ridiculous and how bad stuff
starts I know black people swim I've
seen black people swim what I have never
seen and no one has is a black woman
that just got her hair done get it wet
on purpose
that has not happened since the
beginning of time and black people were
the first people they've had more time
a black woman Will Follow You into a
body of water but just up to her hair
and they should be like ah nope and back
it on out
and then you're just treading water in
the lake are you gonna leave
[Applause]
I took the afternoon off to get my hair
done I have nowhere to be
I saw a black lady leave the hair salon
one time she looked up and started
raining on her hair and she looked up
into the sky and she goes no
and it stopped raining
so you know
still think Jesus is white
[Applause]
I know I talk a lot of crap about my son
up here
but I do want you to know that he's a
very respectful young man and he is a
smart like too smart maybe and he has a
very dry sense of humor
to the point where you don't know if
it's a joke or if you're going to get
murdered
right you wake up the next day in your
life like
[Laughter]
that's funny buddy
good job it's nice funny joke oh my God
I'm alive it's like that kind of sense
of humor
we were walking down the street one day
it was my son and my daughter and I and
uh
an Asian family was walking towards us
and there were seven of them and none of
them were higher
I don't get it
there were seven of them is that like a
weird thing to say
ah [ __ ] legalized pot here's what
happens
you don't have to say anything funny you
just present a fact and people are like
dad you're not gonna
[Music]
be
we were walking towards an Asian family
number seven of them
none of them were higher than my chest
now does that mean I think all Asian
people are short no of course not I know
Asian people are taller than me I'm just
telling you these are the facts of this
particular story
so the grandparents passed us and then
the parents passed us and the children
passed us
and my son slowed down and he looked at
me and he goes
do you think Godzilla was just a
normal-sized lizard
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
and my daughter said isn't that racist
and I said we will figure that out when
I'm done laughing
because sometimes you just got a letter
buck
and I was always such a huge fan of
Johnny Carson I want to show my son some
history right they have a museum there
and everything so we went there and we
had a great time and on the before the
first show we're in the Green Room it
was me a couple friends my son and then
two comedians walked in that I had never
met so they didn't know me and they
certainly didn't know my son and so they
thought he was a comedian
and they were like how old are you and
he goes I'm 18 they go oh you think
you're going to go out there and wow the
adult crowd with your 18 year old humor
yeah is that right is that what you're
gonna do sure gonna tell them about how
you live with your parents and
somebody's whispered to me they go are
you gonna help your son
and I was like nah I sharpened this
stick I know how it pokes
so the guy was just giving it to my son
and he's finally done and my kid goes
yeah thank you very much for that I
really appreciate the advice
um do you mind if I say something I like
about your act I gotta goes go for it he
goes I really like how you smile at the
end of your jokes to let people know
they're finished since the punch lines
don't do the trick
everybody slowly looked at me and I was
just like Daddy raised you right
true
but that wasn't even my favorite at the
end of the week there was a former Miss
Nebraska there just a lovely woman she
was like the town celebrity so nice and
she invited us all to her home to have a
buffet at the end of the week and so we
got there it was my friend Joe my friend
Phil my son and myself and we got there
late and there were no plates left and
Phil is from Canada and I only tell you
that to let you know that he doesn't
care about others
so we walked in and there were no plates
left at the buffet and there were three
plates on the kitchen wall and Phil goes
can I use one of these
and she goes no you may not and he goes
why not
and she started crying
and through tears she told us this story
about how her mom had left Europe with
just 12 plates and the clothes on her
back and then she met the husband and
they had four kids and they all got
three plates and all four of those kids
had three children of their own so they
were all going to get one plate and Phil
goes is that it
she goes yes it is
and he goes well I'm hungry I'm going to
get food and he turned but he had a
backpack on
and it knocked a plate off of the wall
and it shattered
and the only thing you could hear in the
kitchen
was the clock ticking
and this woman sobbing
and my son goes God damn it Phil now
she's gonna have to kill one of her kids
[Applause]
I mean come on
this lady went from crying to laughing
and she goes oh I like you
and my son goes enough to let me pick
which kid
[Applause]
's like a superhero who doesn't know how
to use his powers yet
I'm flying is that a wall smash
thank you guys very much I appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you
you guys are the best thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
hang tight
hang tight I want to tell you one more
story you can sit back down if you'd
like
what a what a weird way to ruin a
standing ovation
when I was starting comedy uh I had zero
money and so my son was about to be born
so I called this booking agent and I go
hey man is there any way you can give me
any work at all I just really need to
make some money and he goes how about
this week and I go Ah that's not going
to work because that is the week my son
is going to be born and I need to be
around for that and he goes well good
luck because children ruin comedy
careers
so I would like to introduce you to two
people that beg to differ
this is my son Isaac
[Music]
pretty good huh
do you uh have anything to say
I'll let you all know that uh I start my
job on Monday
[Applause]
anything
anyone bring their passport
[Applause]
[Music]
uh kids do not ruin comedy careers uh
they make them but more importantly
these two have uh just made my life a
million times better so uh I just wanted
to tell you guys that because I know I
pick on them a lot but they are the best
and thank you guys very much
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
must be wrong
[Music]
get dressed
[Music]
okay
yeah
[Music]
would you let me know
[Music]
close
[Music]